out of shape contribute to global
warming
their ruminants when they're chewing the
card They belch out methane which is a
powerful potent greenhouse gas when they
eat the grass that goes into the room
and which is the first of the four
stomachs that they have it's a big vat
of soupy slop full of microorganisms
which break down some of the grass and
then as you'll see them lying in the
field and they belch up and as they
belch up they bring a lump of the stuff
from the room and up with them and then
chew it again and it's when they bring
that lump of food up that's when the me
thing in fact
in their entirety British sheep are
belching out methane equivalent to about
5 million tons of carbon dioxide every
year
but is it possible to reduce that
contribution from our sheep lot well
that's what this experiment is designed
to try and figure out it's a very
unusual kind of sheep pen built into a
trailer imported over from New Zealand
but they've done quite a bit of this
work and each of these is an airtight
chamber into which an individual sheep
has been put if you think it's quite
stressful for the animals I can tell you
they're looking quite relaxed in here
and what's happening is they've been
popped in this chamber they're spending
50 minutes in here and the researchers
are measuring the amount of methane for
each sheep belch is out in that time
and the whole purpose is to try and
identify the sheep in this block which
are the lower emitters of methane and
then to take those individuals
understand their genetics and which
genetic factors are possibly linked to
that lower methane emission and then
breed from them to establish a low
carbon flock for the future